- I saw our next guest
at a George Strait concert
this summer, and just wow.
Her voice, incredible.
The performance was incredible.
I was so floored.
She was one of Rolling Stones
10 new artists to know.
I did not know that at the time.
And she's here today
with a performance of her latest single,
it's called, "I Can't" and it's
off her album, "Supernova,"
but why don't we chat with her first?
Everybody, please say
hello to Caitlyn Smith.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)
Oh, my gosh.
I'm so excited that you're on my show.
I literally was so floored.
I was so excited.
I hadn't seen a show.
I hadn't seen a live concert
in four years that night
and I was so excited to see George.
And then I ended up
being so floored by you.
I don't know if you saw my tweet,
but I was like, you're incredible.
Just great job. Well done.
- Thank you.
(Caitlyn laughs)
Thank you so much.
I probably didn't know
when you were there,
I probably just would've peed my pants
when I got on the stage.
(Kelly laughs)
So thank you.
That means the world.
And wow, that show was so much fun.
Seeing the king of country music.
Incredible.
- Oh, my god.
How did you end up touring with him?
You're touring.
That's amazing.
- It was incredible.
Well, a handful of years ago,
I was out on the road with
Tim McGraw and Faith Hill
on their Soul2Soul tour.
And they have the same
promoter as George Strait.
So the promoter was walking
around during our soundcheck
and he heard us play and he was like,
we gotta get her on the George show.
So thanks to that guy.
- [Kelly] Oh, my God.
- We did a show at
Gillette Stadium in Boston
with George in 2019.
And he actually watched
us play side stage.
And so, not only am I
playing my first stadium,
but I see the king of country,
like in my peripheral vision
the whole show, I'm like,
aah, this is crazy.
- Oh my gosh.
- And then he asked us to do
a bunch of shows after that,
which was so cool.
(Caitlyn chuckles)
- George Strait was side
stage just watching your show?
You have peaked and it's amazing.
That is amazing.
Oh my God.
I would freak out.
I don't know if I'd like that.
(audience applauding)
I think I'd be so nervous.
I would've been terrified.
Well, what's been your favorite moment,
like touring with him?
I gotta say that picture
was pretty awesome.
Was that Vince Vaughn?
- Yeah. That was so random.
That was definitely one
of my favorite moments
of doing these shows is randomly,
he does these shots between his Encore,
which he gets some friends
together in the back
and then Vince Vaughn
was just chilling there,
so I got to chat with him.
Well, what is life?
That was so random. (laughs)
- Oh my gosh. I love
how texaneers is like,
we're just gonna do this shot
and I'm gonna get back
out there and kill it.
(audience laugh)
I love George Strait so much.
- It was awesome.
- Oh, well, your voice is incredible,
but this is a really cool thing
I wanted to make sure everybody knew.
You founded a collective
called Girls of Nashville.
Tell everybody what that's about.
- Yes.
So Girls of Nashville is a show
that we put on four times a
year in Nashville, Tennessee,
and it's really just a
little showcase of women
that we think are awesome.
We've had incredible artists
join us like Kacey Musgraves,
Maren Morris,
but, you know, we also
keep our ear to the ground
and kind of pull up
young acts that we think,
man, they should get a record
deal or a publishing deal
and love to shine a spotlight
on young women as well.
And so it's this growing
little community that I love.
It's near and dear to my heart.
- I think that's so cool.
You're paying it forward.
And I gotta say,
I think we're meant to be
friends because all of a sudden
you've just announced to all Texas people
that you like to be around
George, Kacey, Maren.
We're all Texans.
(audience applaud)
I'm just saying.
I think we're meant to be friends.
- I Should have maybe been born in Texas.
I love Texas.
(Kelly chuckles)
- Well, you're gonna be
performing, "I Can't,"
after the break.
So what's this song about?
- Yeah.
So this song is about living in Nashville,
you know, for the last decade.
And you know, I'm a totally
different person now
than when I moved there,
and so is the city.
Like, I don't know if you
were there 10 years ago,
but it has changed completely.
- I was there 10 Years ago
- And the song just,
Yeah.
- It's crazy different.
There's like 88 people a
day that move there now.
It's crazy.
- It's insane.
Bachelorette capital of the world.
(Kelly laughs)
But I was driving by downtown
and seeing all the cranes
and all the skyscrapers,
and the idea of this song
hit me of like, you know,
this ain't a 20 minute town no more
don't look the same,
like, that's where the first
lines of the song came from.
And I realized that change
is something in our life
that is inevitable,
but it is not easy.
You know, when we come up
to those things that's like,
we need to let someone go, something go,
things that we need to
fix inside ourselves,
it can be so hard and you
can feel like you just can't.
And so I recorded this song.
A big thank you to my friends Old Dominion
for hopping on it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Casual.
- I love it.
(audience applaud)
- So fun. (laughs)
- I know about Old Dominion
because of Shane McAnally.
My friend, Shane, he works
with them a lot, but yeah.
I'm so mad at him
that we never had a
conversation about you.
I'm gonna take that up with him later.